ooh
good morning Malaya did your voice just
crack I know I was going up up up cuz
it's been so long since we've done one
of those and and you breathe you
abruptly cut me off it's like now cut me
off but you should made it shorter than
it could have been did I yeah I will
ready take it me cutting someone off
sounds so unlike me well how you doing
today says I'm doing I'm doing well I'm
doing really well I'm so excited for
today's show it's actually our last show
of the week yes there were no tomorrow
but because there's no show tomorrow we
actually will have a show on my name is
supposed to be show tomorrow no show
Monday it really all had to do with
counselors snitches schedule so she's
going away this weekend leaving tomorrow
unfortunately my allowance didn't cut it
in order to make the trip so she'll be
back on Monday and we're gonna do show
on Monday and I think it's more
important for you guys have a show on
Monday rather than a show on Friday like
Mondays require the shows yeah more than
I couldn't agree more Jax you're just so
smart and wise oh thank you sister
eventually the longest morning like I
know you have you were sending me
pictures of a precious gem of a man yeah
well chapters last night I just wanted
you to have them I have them and they're
preset in and ready to go but I like
weirdly ran errands this morning before
I got here
what oh yeah I saw your bag of
toiletries yeah well I went to Duane
Reade because I'm going to Mexico
tomorrow night just needed so many
things like you know toothbrush makeup
remover Listerine because like there's
gonna be a lot of people I'm gonna be
talking to and like I'm not trying to be
the girl with that brats you know and
I'm like I live in constant fear that
I'm that girl oh I know there was a girl
in my grade in high school and like that
she was that girl and I wonder if she
knew she was that girl I do think she
also had like a medical diagnosis but I
just wanted to know if like like I can't
ever imagine being that Unseld fillet
right and then I also think that people
who know they have bad breath like I
always talk away from people I think
people think I'm being rude but it's
like I'm doing you the greatest so I go
like this and like up to my chin down
and I talking to my breasts no I like
suck in my words as I go yeah yeah in my
mouth so I just I've been trying out new
like mint gum things and I've just got
the Listerine spray okay also raise is
crazy I think my local Jemaine Reid is
going out of business and like they're
not telling anyone yet but like
everything is mysteriously disappearing
off the shelves it's not everything
docking there's something they're not
telling there's a colonial women on the
wing churning butter and then I also
went to the shoemaker
do you ever go to the shoemaker no it's
such an underrated place I mean you can
get like
new shoes essentially like shoes that
you thought were old are now new again
and I bought these really cute youth
coke toast maker I went to my local
shoemaker obviously use Co toast because
they bought these sandals from Aldo and
like they were mad tight and I'm like
can you make em bigger look at what you
stretch them do you know that's a thing
oh yeah they leave these things in for a
few days he said no he said come back at
five they put him in this morning and
they said come back in five
wow that I was walking around in them
last night I was trying to stretch him
out they were so [ __ ] tight in my you
know and like your skin overflows on a
sandal yeah that's the worst yeah like
baked bread
yeah exactly like loaves of bread
leavening like toasts like red lipstick
on my in the season it's been a while
it's been a while since a change season
because I got my [ __ ] together anyways
we have such a fun show for you today we
have like half the cast of siesta key
coming the most people that have ever
been on the show at one time we have
everyone was really worried that we were
gonna like how to fit like please we a
profession please we were worried too
yeah we figured it out with our great
team and we didn't help and we did also
I feel very weird today because usually
our chairs are situated on like a little
platform but today were directly on the
ground and honestly like but to everyone
else we look the same I'm feeling so
yeah I did I know I just feel as short
as I actually am me to like you know do
you ever go to the bathroom in like a
public place and your feet don't touch
the floor mm-hmm that's usually what I
feel like yeah today I feel like a big
ass adult using the little girl's room
okay so should we keep the chitchat now
I'm like so aware of like our pre-show
banter right are we being too personal
for you guys no but everyone really came
out overwhelmingly in support of the
pre-show chit chat and so to offer a
rebuttal to what I said yesterday which
one good point I heard was like if a
girl or a toaster he's trying to get
their friend into it if she starts
listening to a show and we're going into
like in-depth personal like she doesn't
really care cuz like she don't know us
but someone tm2 me and they were
actually I found it really helpful cuz
then I got to know you even better hmm
makes you think okay
speaking of thinking wait before you
jump in I have thought this morning I
thought that was interesting the
interesting thing was I was thinking
about panic at the disco love and I just
want to say like I just wanted to put it
out there like how happy I am for their
resurgence like they took a mad long
and honestly they could have fell into
the Oblivion like with Fall Out Boy and
the rest of them but now they have high
high hopes for a minute
they had um hallelujah they had the date
of a bachelor the greatest showman like
they really did the Bohemian Rhapsody
cover or today uh-huh like they're just
constantly coming out and one of the
toasters this is why I thought of it one
of the toasters meant to see them on
scene and put a video of them performing
the greatest showman in the group and
they went to they played Barclays Center
like good for them [ __ ] I wish I went
now as someone who plays venues am like
highly aware of other people playing
venues
that's probably an amazing show oh my
god yeah perhaps the greatest show maybe
I don't know we'd have to say we're
gonna recap Real Housewives of New
Jersey right yes we'll do that at the
end is there any other TV we need to
recap it's all i watch no I've just been
watching OC reruns even though she is
not with me and I'm getting ahead of
where he is that's the worst when you're
watching a show with someone and then
someone keeps watching on the other
person doesn't so I know like cos upset
with me that you like what went ahead
without him right but then I know I'm
earning points by creating premium
content at pub with no job I think it's
the most beautiful dog Instagram page
Johnny he's overtaking the Instagram and
honestly I was already logged into five
accounts and like I just couldn't take
the on right now cuz it's fifty with no
job she replaced him
so I'm really happy for you because the
own I know that I have coloring the like
he can use my presets you know I know
how to work with the redheads even if I
don't understand
yeah you do so it's all working out it's
man pup with new job go follow him he's
a medical professional and political
refugee oh also do you know what I got
for him someone gave it to me in the
show and I literally traveled with it
all the way home a stethoscope a
doctor's outfit I do believe there's a
stethoscope you hand a businessman
outfit stuff yeah you have to put him in
and take premium pictures honest it
looked a little small but like he's on a
diet it's fine
yeah he was a tad on guidance Nietzsche
says I heard his jacket in have a
measuring cup and she was under feeding
him for two days yeah it was two meals I
heard he was doing keto yeah no he
wasn't
these can be starved out by his an how
do you feel about keto season I honestly
I don't feel good about it I'm not gonna
lie for those who don't know Kido season
is like Ben's way of life he's not even
on keto he just like eats things
sometimes that would be considered keto
and he did lose like six months ago he
lost like 30 pounds on keto and like
it's over like you're not really on it
anymore like I eat with you I know but
sorry the seasons
but ya know he claims kitto season is
just like a way of life it's not about
the die kita witch it's about like being
king of season and it's [ __ ] annoying
maybe I should call us with Ben tomorrow
um Ben like house like a new like fancy
job and honestly I don't know if he'll
be here that much it's been so long
since I co-hosted with him well because
he got a new fancy job and honestly like
I ain't mad about it but like he won't
be here to fill in for his deadbeat wife
right daddy
you know I'd you know well without
further ado are you ready for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bike I
have your morning toast
um I guess yeah sure hit me with the
Jackie come on I'm ready
pimmy good do again I'll do it
I don't even [ __ ] I'll do it okay first
story Miley Cyrus denies reports that
she's pregnant quote leave me alone
first comes love then comes marriage
then comes the baby in the baby carriage
just not yet okay so none of those
things so no so the baby carriage isn't
coming is what you're saying I there's
the baby
Miley Cyrus took to Twitter to deny
reports that she's pregnant with what
would be her first her first child with
husband liam hemsworth quote i'm not egg
expecting but it's excellent to hear
everyone is so happy for us oh I guess
we're happy for us too cyrus tweeted
referencing the world record egg that
beat out Kylie Jenner's photo is the
most liked Instagram of all time excited
for this new chapter in our lives now
everyone now can everyone leave me alone
and go back to staring at an egg okay
like I called this because I put it on
the chose Instagram like people are
saying she's pregnant like she's not it
was very obvious that one picture that
was servicing was like her shorts were
bunched up and made it look like she had
a brown belly and like homegirl could it
be skinny and she does not even have a
belly but okay Maxine was reporting it
so like you know if okay magazine is
reporting it whatever they're saying the
opposite is the truth right I just
thought as a society we were like so
past calling people pregnant when they
have a big lunch yeah you know like that
used to fly 2007 you know someone comes
that steps out with a belly and they're
pregnant but I thought like that wasn't
like PC anymore it's not but it it's
actually amazing what still flies in
tabloids
right that's it was only written in OK
Magazine and I'll never forget after
Carly gave birth it was also written in
the Daily Mail as fact okay The Daily
Mail
they're not like the PC police you know
they're not but they are like pretty
factual actually they're really tabloid
they're like a buried like they're like
the National Enquirer of the UK but in
the u.s. we give them a little like a
little bit more credibility than that
yeah but after Kylie gave birth I'll
literally never forget I was on a plane
reading a magazine that was a picture of
like the first picture of Kylie she
looked so good and after she gave birth
to stormy and the caption was like new
mom Kylie Jenner struggling to get like
back to her post body free Bobby baby
weight or whatever and I was like are
you [ __ ] kidding me
what like that loser wrote this you know
totally the fattest this man who never
took care of anyone in his life still
lives in this never stays worse yeah
[ __ ] him and his bigger boobs and Kylie
totally well
Miley's not pregnant I'm I'm excited for
her but like I wish she was right and if
she were like that would be so sweet
except I feel like they really plan to
get married on Christmas like all along
so this would have made it seem like
they got Shawn married because she was
pregnant yeah so that's why I didn't
believe it I was like know that and also
she was drooling at her wedding
oh yeah so I don't think you can do a
while you're pregnant it's such a great
call
I don't yeah I mean I know we said it
once and I'll say it again I'm just like
so like here for and happy for the three
emancipation of Miley not even Rhian
meditation like the what's the word hold
on um when like you come back as a bird
when you the a reincarnation she's a new
Miley I said and she's a bird no no but
like has anything no I know but like
when I learned it in school I was like
you know Mac is a bird they taught you
about reincarnation yeah it was like
what do people what happens to you when
you die a couple of different options I
incarnation would be cool yeah you know
I do want to know what it would be like
to be a man ooh you know I don't know
like there's definitely positives like
not having to brush your hair do you
want to know what it would be like to be
a dog like Theo like yes but sometimes I
feel like if I was Theo how like
helpless and powerless ever and it
depress like sometimes he's trying to
tell me something I'm like I have no
idea what you want and like that can be
frustrating yeah as as as depicted in
the secret life of pets also while I was
being you know the great sense each is
about
um and I was talking about on my
Instagram story how hard it was for me
to leave the tags just to go to work
like yeah and how I have major respect
to all the dog parents who do that every
single day and then someone said
something they were like doing even more
depressed because dog ears sob I know I
heard it it's really sad because dog
ears are shorter than human ears dog
days are shorter than human days so what
you left the oh for three hours two
times seven to him that's like a whole
day true because they sleep also like
imagine every time Theo took a nap it's
a new day for him makes you think
totally Wow do you ever feel like there
are some days on the show where like we
just talk at each other and like I'm
just like sometimes I just feel like I'm
waiting for you to stop talking like
you're waiting for me to stop talking
yes I mean I feel like yesterday I was
full of sure's and cool though because
I'm feeling like today I'm just like a
brick wall and yesterday I felt like
highly engaged oh that's good because
yesterday I felt like the wall of shares
cools in total right and today could be
you I remember yesterday like we were
time we were talking about Real
Housewives of New Jersey and I just like
couldn't think of a thought today and
there's nothing worse than someone who
is clearly has nothing to say and keeps
talking yeah no and then then he's just
like and Olivia does that sometimes
we're like you end a sentence just with
words for the sake of saying words but
when you actually read the words like
they don't actually make sense into a
sentence right look Olivia when she's
not listening I know she goes like this
she was and that's just a reality
like it is that's how I know she's not
listening and I called her out on it
once and now like I'm a hyper aware of
it chill and conversation just be like
she's like yeah no I feel that look at
do you okay but I do have thoughts on
New Jersey today oh and I didn't have
thoughts because I watched so long ago
and was fresh for you and it wasn't
pressuring me so story number two ooh
these are cute shoes in an ad teks by
Gabrieli use coats just kidding guys I'm
kidding okay guys if you do want to use
code toast we actually do have a good
opportunity for everyone today because
Jackie is New Year's resolution which
was supposed to be last year and
homegirl didn't do it right
but now this year is to start cooking
it's to learn how to cook and learn how
to drive and what's even crazier is last
year I was watching my time how much
I've been doing every day
me too I think just shows how bored I am
um I had stories saved because I was
still like taking them on snapchat and
putting them on Instagram where I talk
about meet you
Year's resolution is to learn how to
cook but I'm not gonna start until like
someone with someone like hello fresh
partners with me so until I get a Hello
fresh partnership I'm not going to learn
how to cook because I'm not gonna order
hello first on my own because they do a
lot of like influencer partnerships and
not only that like I used to like start
being a person who cooks until like
there's a streamlined way to go grocery
shopping unpack it store it and all that
stuff and that really is hella fresh
like it's not even the cooking that have
a problem with its the pre-cooking work
so it took me a full year I finally got
a hello fresh sponsorship and I'm so
excited to share our kitchen knife I got
the deliveries like obviously I did you
vegetarian mm-hmm and I was curious like
what are they gonna get me they're gonna
be fish I like stinks at my apartment
right the greatest vegetarian options
one a parmesan pasta that looks so good
YUM
- this Mediterranean couscous that looks
the easiest to cook and three like black
bean and shelah tez which if I look that
could you imagine I go from not being
able to cook anything to making
enchiladas so there are three plans you
could choose from classic veggie and
family with the option to switch between
for when your tastes change enjoy fun
menu features with hellofresh is dinner
to lunch 20 minute meals and so many
others if you want to get involved which
I truly believe you should take
advantage of hello freshers special
offer for 2019 get $80 off your first
month by going to hellofresh comm slash
toast 80 and enter toast eighty eight
zero as your code if it's like receiving
eight meals free eighty dollars that's
amazing that's like the biggest $80 is a
lot of food I was would say it's also
like the biggest coupon I think we've
had yeah I think before that we were
like max fifty bucks yeah that's awesome
eighty dollars get hellofresh I'm so
excited to start Kagami to find my pots
and pans don't you feel like when you
say dollars like you say weird I found
that I started saying the word dollars
weird I only say $80 for my show show
yeah yeah $80 $80 or $200 he actually
doesn't say okay next story 5 seconds of
summer is Michael Clifford is in each to
his girlfriend when I was
I know he put a ring on it five seconds
of summer's Michael Clippard announced
on Instagram that he proposed to his
longtime girlfriend crystalline quote I
was lucky enough to ask the love of my
life to marry me in the place it all
began for us in the last three years she
has helped evolve and shaped Who I am in
ways I could never have imagined he
captioned the suite photos that show him
down on one knee quote I couldn't have
asked for anyone better to spend the
rest of my life with
I love loving you crystal cutie wait so
I am like a five sauce stand and I just
want to say like everyone loves five
sauce Youngblood it was in Riverdale
like me and Ben saw a [ __ ] fire sauce
at Jones Beach we were the oldest people
there like four maybe five years ago and
we had front-row tickets cuz like nobody
in the everyone at stadium-- was 12 they
couldn't afford tickets like me and Ben
spent like $150 each and we were front
row like head banging I [ __ ] love five
sauce I'm like such a Stan I'm really
interested in the dynamics apparently
this girl also dated another band member
why I don't know if it's contentious I
don't think that it is but I just want
to know like how that works and I really
hope it just doesn't like effect band
camaraderie well what's so weird is that
I followed this girl like before my
leash before she was dating Michael I
remember I started following her when I
was in college like she just had like a
cute Instagram huh and I think she had
like a fun job and I just thought she
was like a fun person towel I don't even
think she was an influencer I think I
was just following a person and then she
like started get more followers and a
member when two men went to her page and
she's so many followers and I was like
how did this happen like because she
really was an influencer when I started
following her and then I realized she
was dating the guy from Python and she's
also best friends with one of the other
five sauce girlfriends who's just like a
pretty blonde girl who used to date
Leonardo DiCaprio very cute nobody's
like are all of it the five sauce guys
like if you like ran into him at a
Starbucks like you wouldn't really know
who they are but they're like so famous
and they're so rich you know they wrote
like a bunch of like the new Simple Plan
songs but I don't know if they're
popular or not but like I said I'm a
five saw Stan and I read this whole
article that Rolling Stone did on them
and like the five sauce cult was not
happy with the with the article it was
just like a little derogatory like
they're living like that Rockstar life
even though they're like eighteen and
they like live in a house in LA and
there's like cigarettes everywhere yes
right and like Rolling Stone was just
like making them out to be whatever but
okay Rolling Stone why don't you go
write an article on our our Kylie's
house yeah totally please also write
like a love Rolling Stone though really
they give Taylor Swift the respect she
deserves I can I feel like the music
industry ten
to not you know people think it's five
sauce oh five what is the proper way
high sauce sauce five seconds of summer
it's just I'm by the way you know what's
so funny is actually didn't even realize
I've been to two five sauce concerts
because when me and Ben went to one
direction at MetLife Stadium they opened
for them and at the time their only song
was amnesia is that their song yeah I
wish that I could wake up with amnesia
and that was only song we knew and like
me a band like our lighters in the air
you know oh my god that is so five sauce
been at a concert is out of control
what's crazy though is that at the time
it was like five sauce in one D and I'm
be sick one direction was way bigger but
fives house is still have salmon but
there's also a big difference between
one direction and five sauce One
Direction is a musical group five sauce
is a band because they play music they
play there's a drummer there's a bass
guitar rock and roll no they're very
Rolling Stone oh you tell him Jackie
rock on rock out with your [ __ ] out oh
so that's like also sports from Texas
hook I'm sure come UT horns yeah
well I just wanted to put out there that
I'm a five saw stand like if someone is
their manager like I really want to go
to their show but like also meet them
and like maybe become a gripping been
too cool very cool I think it could
happen cuz I and you have to hear how
okay so Ben's like vibe of music it's
like 90s rock band and he's always
asking me to go to like the blink 182
concert site Terminal five and I don't
go because they're all GA and you mosh
right have you ever washed um no not a
choice you have to see these videos of
Ben offense I saw his friends moshing
they basically stand in a circle and
look run and like shove each other and
it's so weird and I will never go but
they so the fact that I like five sauces
like Ben's dream because it's like a
combination of his music and mine and so
I want to go to a five star concert and
mosh
that's the only place I'll do it look
I'm washed with like other sixteen year
olds okay next time five houses in town
call me same with panic at the disco
their new album is so good lie to me is
just like so good and you just do album
meet you I it's my go-to album tells to
do on planes cuz there's four summaries
and it's downloaded offline on my
Spotify but I'm not I know why it's
because five is like they're the first
artist so if you ever went to count all
your that went first and then it gave up
oh that's such a good call won't you
let me so good
beautiful beautiful words thank you next
up Bob in taste wait sorry could you say
[ __ ] before yeah I said rock out with
your [ __ ] out I believe you should talk
it's in a web show anything could happen
icarly over here in her web show nevel
season
Frankie season Margot Sam today or the
Sam can I like wake up every day
thinking like I hope jennette mccurdy is
ok cuz I don't think she is I don't
think she is either and just there's one
mine Dan Schneider did this yeah cash at
her you did this to me
in today's hosting news where you know
we're one door closes and other door
opens for potential morning show host
and Olympic anchors with pink I'm Bob
Kostas and legendary career at NBC after
40 years and they think it's Bob Costas
Costas yeah and you know what he has had
such an impressive career I almost feel
bad for him because he's had 40 years of
like dedicated work and all he will be
remembered for is having pinkeye during
the Olympics in Sochi in Rio whatever
doesn't even matter it doesn't even
matter where it was because all that we
care about is that he didn't take the
day off when he had pinkeye and he was
like using pus and like tears on live
television I really don't think there's
anything grosser than pinkeye you're
like an infectious walking like pus
right and it's like technically there's
nothing wrong with think I like it's not
permanent you know it goes away in a few
days but it's like literally grosser
than like an STD that you didn't see do
you think that when Ben grows up he's
gonna look like Bob Costas cuz I do look
with the glasses no he's gonna look like
the director of Superman yeah but that
guy was like 30 no but like like grandpa
Ben Bob Costas vibes and I'm no mad I
don't know I don't know we'll see if
you're talking about battle law today
just so it's like you're in love with
him or something iconic broadcaster Bob
Costas ended his 40 year career with NBC
confirmed to the New York Post on
Tuesday quote it's all settled quietly
and happily for all concerned Costas
told the Post a network spokesperson
also confirmed the news to the paper but
declined to share details when asked
about the settlement cost 266 did not
refers to specific information but told
the paper the contract
was reconciled quote more than family
his multimillion-dollar contract with
NBC ran through 2021 okay so he's
retiring early I mean maybe he's getting
out before like I don't know scandal
[ __ ] I was gonna say it sounds like you
don't walk away from four years of NB or
three years two years oh my god it's
2019 and you said 2021 right you don't
walk away from two years of NB C money
when also that's only one Olympics
because it's only the winter like it
only happens every two years the
Olympics yeah and also people need to
stop saying that the Olympics happen
every four years like they fully happen
every two years right and it's kind of
annoying like when it was happening
every four years like in my head it was
so much more exciting now they were
happening all the time you know I truly
disagree about every two years is
perfect and I [ __ ] love the Olympics
I love the Summer Olympics and I used to
think I loved the Olympics all facets of
the Olympics curling too and I didn't
even watch one thing from the last
Winter Olympics so I'm a pure there are
a lot of Olympic sports in the winter
that are lit like no I know not like
skiing obviously but the one where you
go and then you have to do a flip oh the
boarding snowboarding Molly bloom yeah
yeah yeah poker face what was that movie
called Molly's game Molly's game yeah
but so this definitely has like eerie
vibes of like Bob not that I'm like I
don't know anything but it definitely
gave me the bag like Bob Costas like
grab someone's ass or something no it's
totally I quit while you're ahead vibe
yeah like Matt Lauer really should have
taken the note of the Bob Costas book
now Matt Lauer was never stopping with
no talking lock door button under I
think about that all the time and
whenever I walk into the office of like
a powerful like meeting like a Hollywood
with a man I'm like he totally has a
button under and I'm like a little
offended that no I'm totally kidding
that's not funny that there's not a lock
yeah yeah okay speaking of creeps this
next story is just like so crazy to
catch a predator host Chris Hanson
charged with bouncing checks you know
this guy from To Catch a Predator never
seen him in my life actually I've never
seen him also what the hell is to catch
a predator it's like um Dateline you
know where they set up these people like
what Liz Lemon's boyfriend Dennis you
know he thought he was talking to a girl
and she's underage and he goes to her
house and then you know Chris Hanson
yeah they have an episode of SVU like
that was Debra Messing and she's like
being so irresponsible I want to kill
her right so they someone has double up
and then they catch
and they catch a predator it's fun also
isn't that entrapment no I don't know I
think it is okay well clearly they've
circumvented please noted in the arrest
report that Hanson told them previously
he would stop by the station - former To
Catch a Predator host Chris Hanson has
been accused of bouncing checks and
failing to pay thousands for products in
Stamford Connecticut according to an
arrest affidavit cited by the Greenwich
Time the 59 year old Hansen was arrested
and charged Monday with larceny for
allegedly cutting bag checks when he
failed to pay a local business owner 13
thousand dollars worth of products
dating back to April of last year wait
sorry you say that again so he was
writing bad checks for he ordered three
hundred and fifty five ceramic mugs 288
t-shirts and 650 vinyl decals for a
marketing campaign which totaled in
twelve thousand nine hundred and ninety
eight dollars he was like making money
he was partnering up with that
influencer have you heard about her yes
where she ordered twelve hundred mason
jars to her studio apartment in new york
now on Amazon Prime no oh my god okay so
I only stock a slice Rogan retweeted
this whole Twitter threat about it was
like this reporter who was following
along on this girl's journey she's like
an influencer and she's famous and I had
heard of her because I read on Man
Repeller like a while ago it was this
girl who got a book deal but she never
wrote it and she'd to give all the money
back to G I read her no she'd refuse to
write it relatable I was like an Adele
be buds I I saw an article about a girl
who was having like having her fans say
like $160 to come to like some sort of
conference right now that apartment and
it wasn't her apartment it was like she
sold the tickets she didn't have a venue
she never opened the door she like never
in her like her mom was cooking the food
for everyone like it was it ended up
being and she was like ordering the
stuff on Amazon Prime literally she
there was a picture of how the twelve
hundred mason jars looked Jackie it was
as big as these two chairs like you know
the boxes that these came in yeah two of
them it was so funny and like I don't
know I don't know if it even ended up
happening but this reporter has been
obsessed with this ground she's been
like following along and taking
screenshots of her instagram stories and
they did a whole article on it instead
the Rogen retweeted and that's how I saw
it
okay I think I started to read the
article and then I was just like not
bored enough thing you know I know it's
shot in Freud season yeah but like it's
kind of depressing you know and it's
like we're in a unique position because
now everyone who's like coming
tumbling down we're like welcome to the
ground with us it's like welcome to rock
bottom but like you're gonna love it
here really like there's more to be made
here horrible like the way that people
cheer on everyone like misfortune taken
down and I mean I I don't even care
because when it happened you don't know
what it's like till it happens to you
totally but for everyone else like
what's your Excuse like seriously the
schadenfreude it's shot in fright season
well they're just like so happy to watch
people be taken now it was really sad
because if you if you follow along this
girl's just wants to put together like
events for like her followers and she
does have a lot a lot of followers
the only thing where I think she went
wrong and it becomes unethical said you
really can't take money from people who
work really hard if you don't have a
venue and she was like I'm thinking
maybe moving to Boston went to New York
a refund and we'll all rebook like
that's borderline irresponsible in you
playing around the people's money ya
know it's irresponsible if you know that
there's nothing for like if you can't
get your [ __ ] together honestly making
events like creating things is really
hard like maybe if she was trying and it
just wasn't happening like she needs
better like she needs better management
he shouldn't be putting on these events
if she doesn't have the bandwidth um I
need to read the articles I absolutely
would find it interesting and also I was
just like we wanna sleep was it full of
interesting factoids that were well
interesting yeah and it made me think
like thank God cam toast wasn't that you
know no because now that camp trust one
was like a smash success like people
feel confident spending money on a
ticket but like to the first eighty were
also about tickets last year who like
literally didn't know what they were
walking into but they ended up with like
a pasta salad and omelet station they
didn't know that and we thank you like
we have been putting on fire festival
right no that's what right and that's
why I mean we we expressed our gratitude
for them taking a chance on some unknown
scenes there but in light of all of this
like wow yeah where do I near Assad so
for you guys to even trust us that much
but it's like everyone in the world just
looks to influencers to fail and it's
really annoying and what I didn't like
about that article was like classic this
is just influencer millennial like
stereotype whatever and that pisses me
off it's like everyone puts a microscope
on like influencers who build businesses
and like love when they bail it's like
so annoying what about the what about
the the converse of that like highlight
all the fills in civil answer businesses
sure but what about the successful ones
what about two girls rock bottom camp
toast making [ __ ] happen yeah no it's
really annoying and like I real
don't like that and I don't like that
narrative of just like influencers are
like scamming the system because for the
most part at least the influencers that
I know and follow they're like really
hard-working and they actually do make a
lot of money and are really successful
like our have highly engaged fans and
it's just it's [ __ ] annoying
no it is annoying and even like the fire
festival documentary made it seem like
like Billy MacFarlane did this because
he is a millennial and grew up in the
Millennial age in the age of the
internet where nothing is real there for
all of us are like that he just happened
to get the furthest it's just it's so
annoying and that's but that's like the
context that I'm not here for I don't
pull me in with like I did one or two
outliers who like brand themselves as
millennial influencers and happen to
[ __ ] up it's annoying agreed or you know
what focus on them but then for everyone
you take down
why don't you breeze one out yeah or two
wouldn't wouldn't kill you
just maybe choose a service maybe yeah
two beautiful gorgeous sisters they live
in New York brilliant amazing vocabulary
of them struggles with her weight
one of them is her dad one of them's
right at I wonder if I know anyone know
if it's a criteria I don't think so okay
Bizen vinyl story is more of you know
business world news story full of
interesting factoids that I found well
very interesting well that's the thing
about interesting factoids they're
interesting cleaning New York's filthy
harbor with 1 billion oysters the New
York Harbor for years has been polluted
and depleted of marine life and I'm
sorry what's the New York Harbor you
know what as I said it I was like that's
definitely not what oh I think it's like
you know John I worked my whole life I
know that there's the East River I know
there's the Hudson River it's not a we
got the Atlantic Ocean and we got the
bay we've got the Long Island Sound it's
a New York Harbor let's pull it up on a
map I literally have no idea ok so it is
hold on where's Long Island that'll that
gives me context out there's an island
so it is between like Brooklyn and
Staten Island upper bay lower Bay I
think it's it's just the best excuse me
I think it's where the East River and
the Hudson River meet at the bottom
right hold on
that's what it sounds like if it's
between snow no no that's the East River
hmm Hudson oh yeah they meet at the
bottom then we start with Basie's in
here okay cool cool okay so so it's just
really necessary for I can read the
actual description New York Harbor part
the Port of New York New Jersey is at
the mouth of the Hudson River where it
empties into the New York Bay and into
the Atlantic Ocean at the east coast of
the United States it is one of the
largest natural harbors in the world now
what the [ __ ] is a harbor what's the
difference between a Pond Lake Harbor
River stream it seems highly on sre to
have all these different words for just
big things of water well I think like
rivers empty into harbors that join up
an empty and to base with empty into
oceans and streams go into rivers and
then Levi's lakes and ponds are like
contained yeah okay if you like that was
like something you definitely learned
you do I remember learning and then you
learned about a peninsula and
archipelago Peninsula has three sides
all surrounded by water uh-huh
archipelago but what the difference
between no Peninsula and island Islands
all surrounded by water not just three
sides so uh what's an archipelago Oh
obviously I know an archipelago
it's a squared plus B squared equals C
squared no it's a chain of islands ooh
rich when are we going okay the New York
Harbor Oh a Harbor so where ships come
in obviously like a port yep in addition
the pier oh that's where the South
Street Seaport is it's on goats there
right and it's at the bottom where they
mean it okay totally okay well our ship
is coming in because the New York Harbor
for years has been polluted and depleted
of marine life the New York Harbor Yacht
may have sold but her ship is coming in
but one nonprofit is working to clean
the murky water and revive its long-lost
ecosystem ecosystem one Easter at time
the billion oyster project has worked
since 2014
to rebuild oyster reefs in the waters
surrounding New York City the creatures
are natural purifiers a single adult
oyster can cleanse about 50 gallons of
water per day
well I'm their reefs can provide a
habitat for other marine life and help
protect New York's shores against storm
surge during rough weather
the group has so far restored about 30
million oysters to local waters but
that's a still a tiny fraction of what
you used to thrive in the area without
the oyster reach the whole shoreline is
fundamentally changed the group's
executive director Pete malinovski told
CNN business what we think Oster reefs
can be an integrated approach can be
part of an integrated approach to
resiliency and proactive planning for
climate change I'm so here for the
cleaning up of our water because I
literally the other day
I saw someone going jet skiing in the
East River and I'm like that's
disgusting like I
consider the East River and the Hudson
River like the water that surrounds
Manhattan I don't consider that like a
river
I consider it literally sewage right
it's not like for recreational purposes
I would rather visit a landfill then
jump in the East River I'm serious it's
just filled with trash we have a trash
problem anyway and then you see it like
crash up on to the side body when you're
at like a dog and you see the East River
like crash up on the side like in the
rate comes down brown it's so disgusting
the Hudson River is definitely cleaner
than the East River yes because it's
larger yeah there's more room for the
dirt to spreader and there's like a
semblance of blue like when the Sun hits
it's like a little blue the East River
is black no it's like one inch by one
inch it's just really very here for it
start with the harbor work our way up
all the way to the Bronx
imagine if we had like blue beaches and
like then we had a beach I'm not like
another economy totally loved it so I'm
here for the oysters and you know maybe
we'll get some pearls uh-huh you're my
pearl we bring yes to key comes out I
have one thing to say about Rihanna's of
New Jersey justice for Margaret everyone
was taking a dump on her life it was
weird there are a few things like she
went her and Jen got into it like they
were both being below the belt and wrong
but when people were defending Danielle
yeah instead of Margaret I was really
like I was feeling sick when Teresa was
saying and everyone saying Margot has
this nasty side we know danielle has the
nasty side honestly I was with Jennifer
up until she said that and I understand
why she said that she was mad at
Margaret's well obviously she's gonna
she's gonna take Danielle side who's
also mad right but she's wrong in that I
do think when when Jennifer came out on
the bus [ __ ] swinging with just her
passive-aggressive like oh but and get
you a gift you got lost in the mail with
a mail-order bride hilarious here's a
nice so you can stab me in the back and
then she had oh oh Chucky said something
about Margaret's husband or something
something about Margaret's kids and then
she was that makes when you talk about
someone's kids like she kept making her
point yeah but she obviously had like
pre-planned all the things she was gonna
say and I was very here for it but she
lost me at the end taken Danielle side
1,004 I thought oh my god Marty when she
went woman Margaret's husband was gonna
[ __ ] knock
Marty out I was live there I was so
shook the two of them are just awful I
need who says that jigna walks into the
room and honestly no Tamia walks into
the room nobody's even looking at my
cousin yell so drop-dead gorgeous
what who even talks like that like
English not me I I can't
I made me like really feeling like sick
in the fact whether it's being bill and
I justice for Margaret but [ __ ]
justice for Dolores it was served he was
served yeah I'm good she needed stick
around
she was [ __ ] you all I told you goodbye
right so I'm here for Margaret and
Delores being friends I always meet you
I'm really disappointed in Teresa for
like not having Margaret's back or not
just staying in the middle no like when
she said in her interview like Martin
like that she felt sorry for Danielle
and that Margaret has a mean side and
the way that March she said that
Margaret treats Danielle like really
harshly but yes but by the way I didn't
understand one thing so Margaret had
told Danielle something that Danielle
misconstrued into being like don't trust
the girls what was it initially that
Margaret I just don't trust anyone
it sounded like Danielle was like
complaining about something in life and
Margaret said to her well then you would
just don't trust anyone you know like
you can't trust anyone it like I would
say that to you like you don't trust
anyone don't trust anyone so then
Danielle took it as Margaret said
technically Teresa and Melissa are under
the umbrella of everyone so she said
tonfa guys you know like that is so
[ __ ] twisted and I see exactly how
that happened I know like Puccini Ellis
show smart cuz honestly both seasons
with Dolores and now with Margaret she
only repeats things that were said off
camera look we really don't know I mean
I don't think Margaret said that but we
don't know no but I know yeah I know for
certain that Margaret did not say don't
trust Melissa um and now Margaret ooh
Melissa are thick as thieves and now and
why would she ever say that to Danielle
and now it's a pattern with what
happened to Dolores and there are people
like that who and here's the thing I
don't think either of them are lying I
think Danielle truly believes that
that's what was said because even if the
conversation even if they could both
watch the tapes back they would both do
feel like they were right because it's
all about like how you're such a sieve
it I have to say my favorite character
on the show is Joe Gorga him and Gia
Margaret's husband being best friends
and then Melissa and margarett being
best friends is the cutest thing ever
he was
defending him against Marty he didn't
let the party get ruined because Joe
would have started a fight then that
would've ruined money is big night I'm
Joe didn't let it and how supportive
Milani how's the word of Melissa and Joe
we're of Milania like watching when they
were when we were watching them watch
Milania was just like so happy no I was
so happy
also when Melissa came in and said to
Joe Gorga Oh Danielle said this that
Margaret said and Joe was like Margaret
wouldn't do that yeah you know it was
helpful insight yeah he'd know like I
was sitting I was like don't you dare
believe this and Joe was like Margaret
wouldn't do that um Danielle is I should
start there
but really there's never been and I
think any housewives history like there
is there's a boys group in the show now
and like they're friends and they have
their own drama
yeah and it's awesome we're getting to
shows it is awesome I can't believe
Marty like where is he I think now that
they're divorced he's close with Joe and
and Margaret
remember when Margot was here and she
was and or no Teresa was here and said
that Theresa said that Marty was staying
at Martha's house after the divorce
right or like on the couch or something
so like knowing that that's coming makes
all of this just even more says he would
be so disgusting also we've only had two
episodes of Danielle and Marty being
married and both times she's like make
show about his money right she yeah it's
weird
yeah mm-hm oh I want to talk about drunk
Jennifer okay I was loving Jennifer when
she was like oh I let her into my house
I'm gonna use the bathroom I want to see
her she was being so funny she's like
not too shabby wasn't she - another sick
what a dumb I think she was joking okay
yeah like when you where I said they put
audio from somewhere else over it
because it seemed out of place no she
was making a joke cuz she was like you
give your kids everything well your
house is nice too right I just don't
like the whole time I was really with
her like until the end I thought she was
being so funny she dress what she wanted
to address but she made up with Jennifer
even though I didn't I mean she made up
with Jackie and I didn't think Jackie's
apology was appropriate at all like and
Jennifer didn't do a good job of
explaining it wasn't what she wrote it
was the fact that Jennifer invited her
into her house and she used that as
context for her comfort for an article
without her permission it could have
been the most cool wonderful happy
positive or you don't care it's just a
weird thing to do yeah and it's an
invasion of privacy and that was a
problem it wasn't what she wrote I need
and Margaret to get along like I meet
you to like them both so much me to
accept what the hell happens next week
your lipstick looks like a monkey's
[ __ ]
yeah nestled like you sucked that's a
Jennifer said oh I know and I'm I'm so
nervous I can't have it get any worse I
know I'm really annoyed I need them to
be friends like who can bring them
together
maybe Dolores once her and when Mark
Marge and Dolores me Jennifer doesn't
really have any like close friends
except her and Therese are like are good
but Teresa and margaret aren't like
besties we got to get them together yeah
but like she's been so poised this whole
time that she goes and [ __ ] you suck
what no she's really funny and actually
always just everything that she says and
this is what I liked about her from the
beginning it's like never what you think
she's gonna say like every time you like
something comes out of her mouth it's
like whoa Wow
didn't see that coming she knew she was
coming to why having so much fun at the
wine thing right I wanted to be there no
say and I feel like she's gonna be so
much fun in Cabo
I need Teresa to start drinking again I
know I'm really excited I can't have
this stupid competition you ever this
storyline that's like taking on it's
like people faking illnesses is a thing
now in Housewives franchise people doing
fitness competitions it's annoying
because she couldn't even eat fruit it's
it I mean I understand that anything
fruit you know like it's like so
annoying I don't want to hear about what
other people aren't eating or drinking
it's someone interesting
agreed and then milania's performance of
a lifetime Fetty WAP Fetty WAP honestly
I wanted to understand it's a bang a
bang it's a banger it is but was she
singing live no of course not maybe she
did that the real thing and the TV
overlaid it I really wanted to hear her
live I can't wait to grow up I'm only
getting older I don't care I don't care
so what so good that takes balls she had
good stage presence I didn't know what
her voice sounded like but I was
actually really impressed from like with
the day one in the studio where she
couldn't even like she was like laughing
to just like being and performing if I'd
a lot of people it's like a big deal and
she was dancing to you she had the whole
thing down they have the full
performance on Bravo TV did you see it
no yeah I saw the whole thing
oh my gosh it's still overlaid with with
like iTunes but the whole choreographies
there okay here for it I'm gonna watch
it and Gia looked so pretty I mean she's
such an adult yeah it's crazy and like
she looked so pretty she was just being
such a supportive society was like a mom
yeah everyone was like loving and
supporting on and it was
really happy moment agreed like they
need like from from Joey gorgeous
christening to where they are now it was
a great moment and I just want them to
stay there I love the drama I don't like
the drama between Teresa and Melissa it
makes me sad
yeah but sometimes I don't know right
now I love the drama in general but the
drama that's happening right now aren't
weird like I want that alliances is to a
that was the problem I had with Dallas
to season two I really couldn't take a
side I saw everyone sides and I liked
people on certain teams but I didn't
like their teammates yeah no I like to
house because I really didn't know what
I was feeling but now it's just but I'd
like to side but I thought that the
Dodgers were clear but here it's like I
just want to move play around with some
teammate yeah me too like what are the
couch is gonna be oh I think it'll be
Teresa Jennifer Lawrence Jennifer Zia
Melissa
Margaret Jackie oh my fur and then
Danielle home sit on Teresa side yeah Oh
charge tie okay so we are going to take
a quick break and we'll be back with
Brandon Garrett
Chloe and Juliet from siesta key if you
love to comment on our Instagram page we
will read some of the comments aloud to
that also if you're watching the YouTube
stream feel free to drop a comment for
any the caspase and we will do our best
to get to them as long as it's
respectful so we'll be back just go get
a snack take a piss do what you got to
do see ya
we are back with the cast will the ones
that matter of Siesta Kate please
welcome Juliet Chloe
Brandon yeah Brenton how do you feel
about the difference between people who
call you black Brendon and Brandon
yesterday
well it's Brandon Brenda knows things
like a UK thing or spin if you guys want
to call me Brenda no no we don't wear
American call me BJ well we're really
excited to have you guys you guys have a
new season coming up on Tuesday
are you okay Margot we're really excited
we got a lot of questions from the
trusters about all of you individually
but tell us when was the season films
for us it feels like seven years since
we saw you on TV I was like right yeah I
think exactly yeah i okay year ago yeah
we okay so we started at oming last
April so that's kind of already coming
up right so it says on like my bio like
I'm finishing up my junior year know I'm
finishing my senior year now Wow a year
ago right which makes sense you guys
know we've been going for like a lot
yeah so yeah this was last summer so
that's April to the end of summer for
sure right here are like watch old stuff
that's like really oh it sounds terrible
because I feel like the last season we
saw you two weren't getting along but
then I master gram you were and it's a
little misleading I'm not gonna lie it's
confusing
yeah and we're very back and forth yeah
her and I are like friends not friends
babies we're getting along right now
well just as they were just well you
know we love your guys we need you to
stay together like I just it's really
frustrating to watch it's gonna be rocky
this season right I think Khloe and I
will always be friends like it's kind of
like sisters yeah it's like I'm stuck
with Olivia yeah low pay and like she
doesn't want the big sister and so of
the four of you which are single them
and who's not right now come on guys yes
and a lot of the toasters I just it's
there where it's not mine they just want
to know why yeah I know I knew that was
coming
like it maybe need a good way I love you
yeah so Alex we're just like so close
it's hard to just end something that
you've had in your life for so long it's
like he's he's really good to me
sometimes and sometimes you see the bad
therefore I understand why some people
would ask that question but you know
he's like my best friend and I really do
go to him for everything and you know
it's like you guys it's like it's hard
to to break friendships like that
especially one that's so deep yes I love
each I love him yeah
Garrett knows the struggle well so Chloe
oh you are dating someone yes but he's
not on the show no and they all know him
really well he's really good friends
with you and at school and is that his
choice of yours yes I would love I bet
okay I they big we all bake but it's
just he it's just not his thing okay
that's fair Sam unrespectable
yeah kind of yeah I mean I can't really
turn I want to be on television
it's tricky don't don't give up hope on
that but it's uh yeah we also we stopped
filming you know at the end of summer so
it's bad time since we've stopped the
things have changed too since we've been
done it's difficult to find like the
line where we don't want to give
anything away yeah right but you know it
has been almost a year yes you also want
to live your life yeah yeah
everything changes like huge yes we're
like sorry we're posting our lives right
yeah and Gary what is yeah
you married oh yeah it's true right now
you talk about this have a drink
take a drink actually would you go how'd
it go it was good yeah are you talking
she was really cool and then what
happened I don't know he won't tell me
he was literally long time nothing he's
very secretive and so where did you guys
meet
I'm on time yeah yeah did you like
bartending it was fun there's a lot of
fun it's not standing it was yeah I did
once my feet were hurting me I mean I
had a couple of drinks yeah and so
Juliet you're now graduating yes what
are you are you gonna do it like I can
get a job um I don't really know right
that's gonna be yeah I'm gonna think I
was thinking about going to law school
also because that's always been
something I wanted to do but I think
then it takes any classmates study but
that's like the dream have been giving
me all his notes but so when you guys
don't film where do you live do see you
John Department in Tallahassee and then
I stay with my parents never come down
whenever I go down just yes to key but
yeah I have an apartment but I'm out all
the time and Chloe what about you when
you're not filling I have an apartment
in Sarasota Siesta Key Sarah and then I
also go back and forth and stay with my
boyfriend who lives in Denver oh yeah
that's what I did yeah yeah yeah like
auditioned we know yeah so I this sounds
like bad like we didn't like try right
yes I asked you they were like they were
like who's hot in your town I was like
oh I know I mean I invited a very beachy
but um so I mean I think with that being
said like we're still kind of are normal
because we didn't liked Riley super hard
to get here I mean I'm still in school
like I would still be in school I think
I mean we got everyone like they hated
the kids from summer house right they
were annoying but oh yeah I do I didn't
know I never hit the bar yeah no I think
people definitely are going like we'll
see comments on her Instagram my tags so
who do you think has changed the most
since the show started
it could be change for the better or the
worse
Kelsey no just yeah elaborate no I don't
know Madison me how so okay so we've all
I'd gone out of our shells a little bit
because that's like a weird you were
kind of like I think yeah I would say
for me like from the beginning like
obviously I didn't show like my true
like fun side because I don't really
know everybody like that but now like
coming into the next season
I might closer everybody's so like I
wonder gets drunk all the time
and schubert it must be Martina yeah I
mean like I just I'm the type of person
I'm super laid-back kind of just do my
own thing and whatnot so but this season
definitely like more outgoing was always
like I thought people I don't think I am
since I was like 11 to be on Rihanna's
Juliet what are your classmates think
like for me the dream is like being like
Instagram and reality TV famous while
also going on college like everyone
knows that I'm cool wait so this is
actually really funny and like I know
some of my friends from school are
watching right now they made a show
called neighbors and friends reality
show at FSU about like frats and
sororities and like relationships in
college and it was like based off our
show like one of my
it was like a father show and like we
can do it better and they don't may
literally like cut to my show like let's
not do this let's do this and it's like
people partying and I see you and stuff
like that so they tried doing that but
like you know Alex's dad I think they
said it's got it so like your CS yeah so
they like did that I don't know like I
don't really know I don't act any
different I I try not to anyway but do
people around campus like no yeah about
the show I think yeah yeah I got my take
some questions from Instagram page BK is
Paulie JAL sorry yogi lmao
yeah there's actually more on it than
ever
watching voiceover Oh God so SOR
I should do ASMR what's that I don't
know my god people like eat pickles into
a microphone video you put pickles know
some people like you and make weird
sounds and it's soothing like puts
people to sleep it relaxes em again sort
of anxiety you should do that this is
from cupcake Kate does Alex love his jaw
wired shut
and furthermore some questions
underneath that how did you guys make
out when he had his jaw wired shut
oh my god so we didn't make out it was
like a month yeah you drinking
everything like what save paper yeah
um we've got so many questions of people
who have been blocked by various yes
Turkey is all of your personal like
online behavior do you block people who
write mean things by your eyebrows so no
I don't know no not it's not my looks
it's one people there's like some I
don't even want to like say something
but there's like some people that are
like very very dark like wish like yeah
oh yeah someone tell me you're gonna
drive to Siesta Key and beat me I think
it's fine you need to go what is your
guys's policy on picking up fans in the
DMS well I use my Instagram a lot
through with like my business with
training so I have to like filter
through like what's no real like for
business and then also obviously there's
a lot of other stuff in there that I
can't I come across and you will get a
lot after being on the show yeah I do
you guys get dick pics a lot not either
I don't see if them all the time shock I
say this is from star steer well
Juliette's mom be on the season she's so
precious
oh sure she is they like okay yeah she's
on it a lot and she like hates it's like
do I need to start getting fellas about
to begun to you know she's the best I
love her and she used to such good
advice she's mean and there we were like
both crap nice that you don't take yeah
are they gonna season a good thing yeah
this is her more Kirkman do Madison and
Kelsey still lived together no no was it
a bad break no it was more like
financially it was just too much for
both okay
Zach more but we see any Carson this
season he isn't any show footage neither
is tarick
yeah without boys and wonders so maybe
just George and then I know I kind of
like at first legs like uh and then I
was like kind of cool these things up
and like make no he was yeah like he
would straight up like he would walk up
to Brandon and be like throw your drink
on me right now like let's go exert too
much no and they hit up all the guys he
says everyone's gay and I'm like that's
really mean of you to walk around outing
people probably not even true like he
went up to me telling me like five guys
were gay like at this party yeah I'm
like don't just up how I don't tell me
that like it's not my business it's
written Carson is on it a little you
don't have other new cast members of
season yeah we do
so we have Kara who is Alex's ex and
Chloe and her met through Alex and
became friends so you would be cheating
great he loves care yeah but Kara like I
mean I don't really care anymore
but Jared parent who is like Madison
Madison facts from way back when
yeah and they have the drama because
when Madison dated Alex way back when we
were like 16 years old she went back and
forth in between Jared and I have this
huge beef but they went to this military
high school and like if you got in a
fight whether you are giving it off
you're like in deep [ __ ] yeah yeah so I
think that's an accusatory yeah the
Jared's like been Jared as a Marine
right yeah ex-marine
yes so funny like I think he's really
nice yeah Jared's the best when you guys
film juji your own hair and makeup
yeah oh well not always no we're like
think about it we have like our two
favorite girls come Cheyenne like better
at that stuff yeah now be I've always
worn we have to do their own hair and
makeup they say they take lessons before
she was hang out with any besides
machinae any other like reality stars
before they actually know me - we love
me I feel like we're like bubbled ah
yeah we are I've been mentored by
Spencer Pratt yes we know him did you
come to see us to ki way to like sober
or something
nothing like a no when he drinks no
we're not drinking with us
yes no he wasn't I don't know I just
don't think he drinks like I'm yeah he
drinks like 1942 he's like obsessed with
you he's amongst us with him I'm
obsessed with her oh yeah I mean like
are they working for you yeah I fight
with one next to my bed that he gave us
on a string actually he said he sent us
all a holiday card
[Laughter]
well he loves Madison so it's probably
because you cheated on Madison yeah yeah
sorry let's not talk about now on this
season yeah yeah she was stirring it up
yeah that's her yeah let me just just
because it was a long time ago so you
were dating Madison mm-hmm you cheated
on Madison with canvas no clothes almost
cheated on her with a brandon routh yeah
I'm canvas solid oh yeah and I and then
started thinking of my package right
right age old dad were there Madison
older when people find out that I'm oh
yeah I knew it I would live you and I
know Margo was the youngest yeah so this
is a good question the new cast mates
are they people who already live in
siesta key or they're just like your
friends from school or what Aaron's from
siesta key Cara's family has always
vacation there yeah and Tara went to
college with Alex go then did she come
to you guys and like having seen the
show being like I wanna be on the show
or like you reach out to her or she was
just really hanging out no it was like
really fooling me yeah Chloe it was like
I want to piss Juliette off baby do you
regret that decision
not at all our patient can be still
hanging out no this has a new girl yeah
and is she on the show yes you is it
more [ __ ] castmates inventor from
rules many people a lot of them come and
go though I feel like yeah yeah like
Carson's not on it as much as he was
just like Paige isn't on it
Hannah's not on it anymore either I also
think that's for the best she's pissing
me off overall this is a great man she
once saw her fighting with her boyfriend
I forgot we're in the city they stopped
it yeah they do yeah no they're like
fighting in front of me in the street
that was just what
actually he gets mad 2news look oh my
that's Stephanie they spent whole
Reynolds how many each of you how many
swimsuits do you have to buy when you
guys start filming oh my god I have read
150 swims yes
yeah I went every time I have like a new
scene well we were looking for photos of
you guys to post on our Instagram to
promote your appearance and I truly
could not find a picture of Garrett on
Google without a shirt on with the shirt
on oh sorry with the shirt yes I do I
like genuinely don't mind that yeah
healthy dating she's dating someone
she's saying her boyfriend Jacob lives
in Arizona he's a hockey player and I
know he comes he comes for a little bit
yeah yeah it's like her highschool
boyfriend and she got back together with
him Kessler's like yeah Garrett I'm
gonna cheat on you and now I'm gonna go
back to my ex boyfriend right after as
well okay final question question this
is such a good question choice remember
like in the Disney Channel days there
was like The Suite Life of Hannah
Montana like these crossovers which is
Hannah Montana
Duncan Cody oh wait there was another
one yeah that's so how would you guys do
Laura Bama key I just yeah they've been
together for like three months out of
time but we like every day together I
don't know how they do it and I think it
would be very interesting for us to do I
mean anyway almost killed each other
they're actively dying all over the
house Zoey's bathing suits were hanging
from a chandelier I took out Alex they
like hung up all my swimsuits on the
chin and they're all this stuff I threw
it in the yard spring catch up all of it
yeah we can tune into the new season of
siesta key on Tuesday on MTV what time
9:00 night it and it's a two episodes
four hours yeah yeah
put your towers yeah episode 1 & 2 I'm
good thanks I'd like it I don't know I
like it a lot oh yeah we're dying oh
yeah these are I feel like network at
the upfront yeah that's the film of our
generation curvy and on that Thank You
toasters for listening to the morning
shows the Millennial morning show thank
you I was trying to say
we both have Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and we're
also available as podcasts anywhere
podcast or listen to make sure to tune
into the premiere of siesta key this
Tuesday yes
yeah clock on MTV you'll see you on
Monday bye thank you
you